- All right, y'all,
let's close out the hour
with something delightful from
the world of social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(funky music)
Everyone loves miniature stuff.
It's just fun and it's cool.
Doll houses, train sets,
perhaps even a diorama.
Well, an artist in
California has gone viral
for her itsy bitsy recreations
of movie and TV sets.
These are so cool.
Here's her version of Monica's
apartment from Friends,
which is incredible.
And this is the comic bookstore
from The Big Bang Theory.
Like how much time?
This is the bedroom from ET.
And here, here is actually
Jerry's apartment from Seinfeld.
She's got all the greats
in there, that was amazing.
She's so gifted, so talented.
Let's get her in here.
Say hi to Bridget, y'all.
(audience cheers)
So, the details are insane in these.
Like, first of all, how
long does making these take
and also do you make everything by hand?
- Yeah, I pretty much make
just about everything.
They could take me three weeks
to a month to two months.
Just depends how big they are, their size.
Some of the details are very
intricate, like the comic books
and the cereal boxes
for Jerry's apartment.
I like getting all of the props
to match what the sitcom
has on them or the movie,
because I'm really obsessed with details
if you haven't noticed.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- I've been obsessed since I was a kid.
My grandma used to collect miniatures
and she said no touching.
So of course, when you
tell a kid no touching
they become more obsessed.
And I've been doing this my whole life.
Even throughout college, I
couldn't focus on schoolwork.
I just had to get to that
doll house when I got home,
because it was just burning inside of me.
- Because someone told
you not to touch it.
It's just who we are. (laughs)
So, I have a question.
I heard that celebrities are reaching out
'cause they want one of their own, right?
- Yeah, I've been so surprised.
I saw, I opened up my TikTok
and I see John Stamos asked a question,
"Can you make a Full House mini?"
And I had to check twice
to make sure that was his
real account and it was,
so I was shocked.
I said, yes, and I'm working on it now.
So this is a work in progress.
It's a big build, but I'm
really excited about it.
I can't wait to show everybody.
- That's so cool.
And it's so special what
you're doing for people.
It's such a unique talent
and it takes so much time.
It's gotta be so meticulous.
Congratulations on just being awesome.
It's amazing what you do.
I'm liking your post right now, Bridget.
(audience cheers)
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of Friction, the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and just creating as amazing as you do,
so they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Oh, great.
I'm gonna spend that on minis.
- [Kelly] I love it, I love it.
Well, thank you so much, Bridget.